all right let's talk about the emmy so
look hollywood is just awful i say that
as someone that lives like two minutes
from hollywood
hollywood itself i mean the physical
location of hollywood
is an absolute disaster if you want to
see what a dystopian future looks like
drive to hollywood sometime and just
drive down hollywood boulevard and what
used to be so great by the chinese
theater
and uh you know they were all well
there's many theaters there and just
like
what was so cool about hollywood you
know the stars the walk of fame and like
all these cool bars and you and comedy
clubs
and places to listen to like you know
groundbreaking musicians and awesome
clubs and all this stuff it used to be
so awesome there really was something
cool about hollywood at some point
and really for decades probably now
hollywood has just become this woke
disaster and then because it's
here in los angeles with these with our
ridiculous progressive mayor eric
garcetti who have
did are they sending him to india yet or
not do we know he's going
all right so this is fantastic news can
we confirm that's absolutely official
that is legit
yeah it's official so eric garcetti is
going to be our ambassador to india so
we're getting rid of them
which is wonderful i mean that's really
great i should i should have we should
have had shots on the show today i
should have done a shot right now
um where we're getting rid of him but
anyway all the you know all the policies
that these people bring in it expands
the homelessness and the drug use and
the tent cities and all that so
hollywood's really disgusting right now
uh actually my uh my girl who uh who
does my hair she lives in hollywood and
she great little girl like
totally cool normal you know she lives
in a little walk up there with her dog
like a homeless person literally was
chasing her down the street two weeks
ago like it's just
it's just awful there anyway that's the
physical part of hollywood but the
the underneath part of hollywood is the
way they run the business and we all
know it's just become this woke
disastrous thing and it's ironic
because you know they're really here to
make money and you'd think that an
industry like hollywood or any industry
that's here to make money wouldn't want
to alienate basically half the country
but that seems to be the route that
they're going and vocism destroys
everything
so they emmys now which no one watches
anymore right the ratings go
down every year can we get a number on
that of what the ratings
have dropped with the with the emmys
over the last couple years they are no
longer going to have
actor and actress awards we are going to
have
uh performer it's going to be performer
good god help me
uh we got some quotes here from fox news
the emmy awards are giving nominees the
option
to be more gender inclusive with their
statues
the television academy's board of
governors announced monday that it has
approved rule changes that will allow
nominees
an option to request that their
nomination certificate
and possibly emmy statuette use the term
performer
rather than actor or actress the move
answers recent calls from
gender non-conforming stars to make the
award system less dependent on pronouns
and gendered casting
no performer category titled actor or
actress has ever had a gender
requirement for submissions
the television academy wrote on tuesday
via deadline
now nominees and or winners in any
performer category titled actor or
actress may request that their
nomination certificate
and emmy statuette carry the term
performer
in the place of actor or actress
look guys i don't think this story is
like the biggest thing like this is one
where you can just sort of put it aside
at the end of the day you know sometimes
we do some important stuff like voting
stuff
is important the critical race theory
stuff is important all that kind of
stuff
uh this is this type of story though
that i wanted to do
because it just is more evidence that
they just destroy everything thank you
for that michael september 2020 so last
year's emmys
were the lowest uh all-time
6.1 million viewers i'm actually shocked
that it was that high but
you can see what they're doing they're
destroying their own industry and that
was making me think about something
i'm sure some of you guys either read
the book i believe the author was bill
carter if i'm not mistaken
the author of the book late shift the
late shift it was also a made for tv
movie on hbo about
20 25 years ago and what it was about
was
uh the the when johnny carson
left the tonight show and obviously he
had been at the helm of the tonight show
for probably 30 years something like
that
that david letterman who was at nbc at
the time really wanted the tonight show
and jay leno was also subbing in for
johnny carson all the time and he really
wanted the tonight show
and nbc was jockeying like what do we do
here they wanted to give it
to leno but letterman really wasn't
going to stay
i don't have to get into all the
specifics of all that obviously you guys
know what happened leno
got the tonight show and it actually did
well in the ratings for 20 years
and in a weird way i never loved jay
leno but i sort of miss him now because
these people are all such partisan hacks
but letterman left and then did i guess
what he called the late show on cbs
the reason i mention all this is there's
a really great moment
in the movie where letterman is like
freaking out because his whole life he
wanted
the tonight show he wanted the tonight
show that was hosted by jack parr and
johnny carson and all the great people
before that and his manager
one of his like close confidants he's
like he's like dave you got to get over
it
you think you're getting the johnny
carson tonight show
but it's damaged goods it's damaged
goods
and that's sort of what all of these
awards will now be
we will do everything based on equity
and inclusion and we will say that we
have to have
you know more black trans winners of
genderless categories of acting and
lighting
and all of these things but the entire
thing that they'll all be going for
will be damaged goods it will not be
like getting an
emmy when maybe it mattered i get it an
emmy in and of itself is not the most
important thing in the world
but i used to care about that sort of
thing like it was fun to watch those
things and fun to watch actors you care
about
and good pieces of art like we need art
right we need music we need movies
and things to capture our imagination
and the rest of it but in essence
the emmys are now damaged goods
hollywood is damaged good so all of
these people that will be like yes this
is so great
we'll have diversity and equity and
inclusion and there won't be actors and
actresses we'll all just be performers
and you know we'll and then 70 of the
people who win will be black trans
latin x people with a limp and a lazy
eye and everything else
and what they will be winning is not
really an emmy at that point
it will be damaged goods so
that's what i think about that again
this isn't the most important story but
it's like
all right let them the beauty of this is
let
them destroy their things let them
destroy their things and how about the
rest of us
keep building things that's that's my
plan